[Musica]
ecco il tema che ha scelto di
condividere con voi questo tema c'è la
parola matematica io non l'ho mai amata
sono sincero però sin da ragazzo
desideravo essere felice pienamente
guardavo tanti miei amici che avevano
già rinunciato alla felicità e si
rifugiavano per avere questi spazi di
spensieratezza all'abuso di alcol oppure
all'uso del proprio corpo del corpo di
una persona di un'altra persona o
all'uso di stupefacenti
e questa cosa mi faceva riflettere
possibile che abbiamo perso la capacità
di stupirsi è possibile ascoltare un
giovane che dice non ho più voglia di
vivere la vita fa schifo che paranoia e
si ricorre quindi a ciò che distrugge la
vita per vivere questi spazi tra
virgolette e non ho mai accettato mi
sono messo un po alla ricerca ho una
bella famiglia
ho tanti amici ho tanti amici eppure in
queste relazioni che può essere
l'amicizia può essere avere una famiglia
dietro può essere avere un partner un
compagno una compagna
eppure ho scoperto che il mio cuore si
riempiva per un max di 60 per cento 65
per cento c'era una parte del cuore che
non si riempiva mai nonostante aumentavo
gli amici nonostante avevo la sicurezza
di persone che mi amavano oppure
rimanere una parte vuota e quindi
rimaneva questa insoddisfazione che
tante volte i genitori lo dicono a volte
gli adulti tra di loro lo penserà ma
come mai a tutto eppure cosa ti manca
eppure perché non riesce a realizzarsi
perché non riesce a stare bene perché
non riesce a vivere bene allora mi sono
messo alla ricerca per l'operazione
matematica della mia vita volevo che il
risultato fosse amore con la a maiuscola
e quindi in questa ricerca nello sport è
un po supportato dalla mia famiglia mi
hanno spinto mi hanno proprio un po
spinto al volontariato perché ho di mio
non l'avrei fatto non mi sentivo una
persona sensibile altruista anzi mi
sentivo egoista volevo ricercare la mia
strada a tutti i costi senza pensare
agli altri però la mia famiglia mi ha
dato una spinta e mi sono ritrovato
pur non volendo a fare amicizia con
delle persone che avevano una disabilità
delle persone che avevano un disagio
delle persone che avevano magari una
malattia anche grave e inizialmente
questa cosa mi spaventava per dirmi che
non è solo per chi è portato è una
grande bugia una grande menzogna e mi
sono ritrovato quindi ad andare al mare
con degli amici disabili che altrimenti
non sarebbero potuti andare al mare
e c'era una ragazza che si chiama lucia
e di barletta e noi siamo stati una
settimana al mare e non si è mai fatto
il bagno in quei giorni nel nostro il
mio compito era di aiutare le persone
entrare in acqua riportarle poi in
spiaggia asciugare stare con loro ed era
bello vederli sorridere questa cosa
banale a che fare un bagno al mare per
chi vive al mare
iniziamo ad aprire a farci il bagno qui
a barletta già da quando ero studente
così già dalle medie è l'ultimo giorno
convinto luci ad entrare in acqua
nonostante la conoscessi solo da sei
giorni dai dai riuscirà ti prelevata
diventano in acqua alla fine l'ho
convinta siamo entrati in acqua è invece
una ragazza costretto a stare sulla
sedia a rotelle è scoppiata a piangere
allora subito mi sono sentito inadeguato
detto video non ti puoi improvvisare sei
stato stupido hai fatto soffrire una
persona
lei mi ha stretto forte la mano e con
questo ha pianto e ne ha detto grazie a
oggi giorno più bello della mia vita
perché il primo bagno che faccia 30 anni
allora io ho provato ho provato
un'emozione da tremare le gambe mi sono
sentito quasi di svenire
e questa cosa mi ha colpito perché sia
una persona mi dicesse quando baciato la
ragazza di cui è innamorato
ho provato questa emozione dico lo
capisco ma nessuno ne aveva raccontato a
nessuno mi aveva insegnato nessuno
educatore nel suo maestro
nessun sacerdote nessuno mi aveva detto
che andando con una persona estranea che
non conosci con una disabilità che di
solito è costretto a stare da sola che
non esce mai che noi pensiamo che non ha
nulla da darci vivere con lei è
un'esperienza di questo tipo vivere
quale emozione un amalgama e raccontato
nessuno mi ha sconvolto al che ho scelto
tornato a casa di andare a trovare lucia
tutte le settimane perché avevo bisogno
di restituirli lei mi ha fatto un grande
regalo fuori dicevano ah ma che bravo ma
io in realtà lei ne ha fatto un
grandissimo regalo
e di lì a poco conosciuto un altro
bambino di 9 anni con la tetraparesi
spastica abitava un quartiere periferico
di barletta pap alcolizzato che non ha
mai accettato sua mamma dolcissima si è
ammalata poi è morta questo bambino non
si lavava da diversi giorni quindi la
mamma ha contrattato mia mamma mia mamma
mi ha chiesto di andare sono andato sono
diventato suo amico aiutato nelle
faccende quotidiane gratuitamente e dopo
un mese che lo conoscevo l'ho portato a
mangiare una pizza
lui non era mai uscito perché il padre
non voleva si vergognava di avere un
figlio di saab dall unico figlio non
andava a scuola perché fino a fine anni
ottanta metà anni 90 non era garantita
l'accesso alla scuola per i bambini
disabili
insomma alla fine ha convinto il padre
da poterlo portare fuori siamo andati in
pizzeria gli ho spiegato le pizzoli ha
scelto le quattro stagioni quando è
arrivata questa pizza
lui è saltato dalla una persona come la
mia amica concetta con la stessa
malattia è saltato dalla sedia a rotelle
e si è commosso
io sono entrato in un altro mondo sono
andato fuori di testa
guardare il suo sguardo alla sua mozione
ho detto mark auguro una cosa quasi
banale che per noi non ha senso mangiamo
pergola scegliamo i cibi più prelibati
ma non ci dona questa gioia
allora mi sono detto luca questi amici
non rilasciare mai più sono diventati
con per me degli occhiali da vista
io ho la necessità di mettere di
indossare questi occhiali per andare in
profondità nella mia vita per arrivare
al fondo del mio cuore per vedere la
bellezza in tutte le cose sono andato
con concetta questione amica a 60 anni e
sono molti genitori e vive con me da da
cinque anni quindi siamo come dei
fratelli un per me la sorella siamo
andati l'ho portato anche a mangiare una
pizza in tutte le mie cose a max mara ha
chiesto da tempo
eros tra incasinato abbassa il
finestrino e stavamo sul lungomare le
guarda il mare guarda il cielo sospira
dice che è bello io in tutti i miei
messaggi che mi arrivavano i miei
pensieri ha fatto fermare il tempo hanno
la capacità di farti rallentare di farti
fermare di guardare attraverso i loro
occhi qualche regalo grande e poi
attraverso la vita che svolgo la
missione tra scelto sono stato in africa
con 200 bambini orfani e poveri tornata
in italia
ho iniziato a cercare i poveri i
cosiddetti scarti gli invisibili coloro
che delle volte associamo operazione
anti degrado sono andate a togliere i
materassi a gente che non posso deve
andare poi dicono no li abbiamo inviati
alle caritas varie ma ci sono pochi
posti le persone restano fuori
non è vero il vero degrado che un essere
umano e per strada
no che un essere umano mette un
materasso per dormire fuori è quello il
loro degrado
allora mandando in strada con i giovani
porto a tanti ragazzi andiamo da questi
amici senza tetto
ho scoperto molti di questi sono persone
anche nostre connazionali sono molti
papà separati o persone che soprattutto
uomini il 90 per cento e hanno perso il
lavoro prima sono finito a dominio in
macchina e poi per strada persona che
non erano abituate che non erano dei
clochard per scelta non hanno la
psicologia di chi si rintana per strada
non vuole saperne niente non è abituata
a soffrire ad essere solo e ho scoperto
che la loro povertà non è aver perso
tutto e aver perso tutti
ho scoperto che il povero e più povero è
colui che perde tutti che non ha più
nessuno perché se avesse qualcuno è
quello il primo welfare noi delle volte
disdegniamo le relazioni noi calpestiamo
le persone che ci sono vicino non li
apprezziamo ma ho scoperto invece che
sono la nostra vera ricchezza ma l'ho
scoperto solo andando in strada solo
incontrando quel papà separato che non
ha più nessuno e dice voglio morire
voglio farla finita
allora andiamo con i giovani dico sempre
ragazzi ricordate il loro nome
chiedetegli quale il loro pasto
preferito il loro colore preferito
perché la settimana dopo andiamo tutte
le settimane li portiamo quel pasto la
maglia di quel colore e quella persona
dice ti ricordi di me
no dai allora non è vero che non valgono
niente allora per qualcuno esisto grazie
forse noi cerchiamo anche di togliere
dalla strada e non è che andiamo lì da
un panino e basta il panino e una scusa
ma lavoriamo per togliere quella persona
della strada c'è chi dice no io voglio
restare qui sto male mi manca la mia
famiglia però non mi lasciare soffrire
da solo continua a venire allora questi
giovani che vengono installati con il
cuore il fuoco nel
cuore sentito un fuoco dentro in
quest'incontro allora ecco per me la
matematica dell'amore si chiama
quest'incontro scoperto che se tu metti
un giovane o un adulto un disabile è un
povero un senzatetto una persona che si
trova nel bisogno sutura mette insieme
il noi rappresentiamo il giovane
l'adulto che già pieno delle sue
relazioni quindi che aveva un compagno
un partner dei figli ha già tutto questo
però gli manca quel 30 per cento manca e
non c'è nient'altro nessun ato la
capacità di riempirlo allora
nell'incontro con concetta nell'incontro
con lucia dell'incontro con questo
nemico senza tetto allora concetta
diventa per me innanzitutto liberante mi
libera dal mio egoismo mi libero dal
pensare che i miei problemi sono
insormontabili
mi libero dal pensare che la mia vita fa
schifo che non ha senso è la mia energia
nucleare nella vita mi cambia il volto e
io lo stesso tempo per lei su mosley
bear ante lei viene liberata dalla
solitudine viene liberata dallo stare a
casa a vedere le quattro pareti di casa
viene liberata dal pensi come sola viene
tentata dal fatto che forse è meglio se
muore altro no è meglio se sceglie una
strada di morte ma la mia amicizia
invece è una strada di vita e poi col
mio amico senza tetto io lo liberò
allora dalla solitudine lo libero dal
pensare che non vale niente lui invece
mi aiuta a rivedere le mie relazioni a
capire che sono importantissime torno a
casa e sono felice di abbracciare i miei
figli sono felice di abbracciare i miei
amici sono felice di abbracciare la mia
famiglia
grazie a quest'uomo canali pensate un po
che che potere che potenza che c'è io
dico qui c'è una felpa dove c'è un senso
unico a mare per scelta è l'unico senso
e il senso unico e solo così solo in
questo amore donato a persone estranee
sconosciute fuori dai tuoi interessi che
secondo te forse non siano meriterebbero
eppure solo in questo incontro c'è la
piena corrispondenza del cuore il cuore
arriva a quel cento per cento e quindi
c'è un volto bello sei sereno e la forza
per vivere per combattere sai quando va
a dormire per chi ha vissuto per
qualcuno è un motivo per alzarti per
continuare a vivere
[Applauso]